Who saw the movie,
the Matrix Matrix was banging movie to
me.
And the reason why I appreciated it so
much was because at the end when Neil
like realize his potential,
he started to see the binary code.
You remember that?
The whole world.
That's where I'm trying to be spiritual.
I'm trying to see the word of God and
the whole world's,
every time that agent throws a punch,
I'm like,
I see you.
You know,
I'm just catching this patch of,
you know,
so I don't,
I'm not afraid.
You know,
I'm not afraid because I'm starting to
see that,
you know,
things are just,
situations materialize themselves and
he's an agent.
Here's the trick is that you have to
remember that sometimes you can be an
agent,
you can be an agent for it to yourself.
You can be an agent against someone else
and not even realize that you're being
used.
You know?
Let me tell you another thing about the
matrix.
I was always confused about it.
I always thought that,
you know,
the Matrix was battling the enemy out
there,
picking them out.
I'm going to find those enemies,
get that enemy.
Until I realized that until you
conquered the enemy and yourself,
you can't deal with anyone.
In order to be used by God,
you have to really be used.
You know,
we always want to be used for the
glorious jobs.
Look,
God put me on a stage in front of the
people in the grammy show with a nice
dress on.
Let me just praise your name.
But that's not being used sometimes in
order to be used,
you also have to be humiliated.
It's be humiliated.
Sometimes you have to be kicked and
beaten,
and in that situation,
the person who was kicking and beating,
he's feeling more pain than you are.
You know,
love is,
is an incredible thing,
and we don't know love like we should.
We always talk about,
I have unconditional love.
Unconditional love is we don't even know
it because if a person stops stimulating
us,
we stop loving them.
You're not interesting to talk to
anymore.
Goodbye.
But that real love,
that love that sometimes it's difficult,
difficult to have.
That's that love and that's a confidence
builder.
Okay.